well the title of the book is money and
banks in the American political system
and I decided to write it because I was
living in Washington and I was actually
working on another book about the IMF
and the World Bank and the American
Congress and the financial crisis
happened and what I found as a result of
that was that there was a pretty big gap
in the literature just for anyone who is
educated and wanted to follow the crisis
about how and why different institutions
were responding so why was the Federal
Reserve doing this why would Congress
involve with the tarp why was the
president involved or not involved and
then we had an election and things
changed again when new appointees came
in so because of that experience I
decided to try to put it all and draw a
map in a one accessible place where
people could understand looking to the
future how the political system works in
this area and how the agencies do what
they do well so much of the book is
about how our American political culture
infuses this system with good and bad
things that have made it possible to
have the vibrant dynamic financial
services sector that we have but at the
same time the political system has been
a source of crises and so there's a good
side to it and a bad side and so the
book starts with a historical review of
the of the development of the American
financial system going back to the
American Revolution and paying off the
debt of the Revolution and then our very
interesting history with central banks
and I say interesting relative to other
advanced industrial democracies so
that's the the first segment but then
during the civil war the government had
to pay for the costs of the war with a
financial system that was pretty
unsophisticated relative to what else
existed and so we started to have a
national banking system in the civil war
that that exists alongside the state
banking system so the point here is that
the same things that fuel American
politics in other areas what does the
state get to do versus what does the
federal government get to do so
obviously in the Civil War the big
question was slavery but there were
other questions as well about who would
issue money who would regulate banks all
of these same questions
were present in American politics and
they have it just like the issues of
slavery haven't gone away and the
residual effects of the Civil War
haven't gone away in that area they
haven't gone away when it comes to banks
either what happened in the American
experience is that the United States
industrialized in such a way that the
major American corporations were out
there before the regulatory agencies
appeared so you think about major
corporations United Fruit even Standard
Oil and the major banks Citibank being
one of them they actually existed before
the regulatory reforms of the Great
Depression in many countries are our
peers our advanced industrial peers they
were much more in tandem when they
developed so in our country we've always
had a lack of comfort with the
centralization of power in our governing
institutions and also in our banking
institutions and as everything else in
the United States is contested between
the state and the federal government
it's no different in banking and some
areas of the United States were much
more comfortable with large banks that
operated internationally so that would
be the Northeast New York State
obviously being the preeminent example
and then in the south there was much
more hesitancy and reluctance about the
role of banks and even more reluctance
out west so early in American history
some western states outlawed banking
entirely the the reserved fractional
banking system so when the Federal
Reserve was created it was a compromise
between people who wanted the government
to control the central bank so we have a
Board of Governors in Washington and
then people who wanted to have more
control by bankers out in the region so
we have a system of regional central
that a regional Federal Reserve Bank
which we have one here in Cleveland
there's one in Atlanta you know and so
on so Chicago so on and so on
so this was a compromise at the time but
it compromised it didn't work very well
because everybody was making policy so
during the Great Depression that system
was altered and and we now have a
centralized monetary policy system in
the the FOMC that's located in
Washington but until that time you know
the Federal Reserve had
like to these different characteristics
well like you pointed out the SEC is a
creature of a different era the Great
Depression and the collapse of the stock
market so at that moment in American
history it was perceived that we needed
to regulate securities markets up until
that time it had only been regulated at
the state level and so creating a whole
system of a securities regulator with a
completely different notion of how to
regulate the idea with with the
securities market says let the buyer
beware
so give people transparent information
and let them decide whether or not they
want to buy this stock and if you lose
your shirt it's it's your own fault but
that's a very different philosophy than
bank regulation which is to try to
prevent a catastrophe from occurring
then we have other agencies like the
Office of the Comptroller of the
currency so that's a part of the
Treasury Department that regulates banks
that's a product of the Civil War so the
whole necessity of regulating banks the
perception when we when we established a
national system of banks so these
different agencies have always responded
to different constituencies and they
regulate different banks so the
additional agency that you can see why
you needed a map for this so the
additional agency that we that is very
important as the FDIC the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation which is
also a creature of the Great Depression
and the notion that people need to have
Deposit Insurance so they won't there
won't be a run on the bank because they
know that their money will be there well
the FDIC has different interests in the
political system because it regulates
different banks but also if the banks
that are regulated by the OCC or the
Federal Reserve fail the FDIC has to pay
out on those so it tends to be a much
more conservative regulator because it
doesn't want to have to spend its entire
insurance fund bailing out the banks
that are regulated by other regulators
so these different agencies come from
different eras but they also have
different purposes based on what role
they form but also what banks they
regulate I don't know if it's helpful
doubt but I kind of think of it like if
you want to think of an analogy to a
person this might be overly simplified
but you say well I have
um I to write checks so that's the
Treasury the Treasury is the the part of
the system that pays out for the
government and taxes people so it takes
money in but it the Federal Reserve is
the bank so that would be like you know
around here would be Huntington Key Bank
Chase one of the one of the banks where
you would you would keep the money on
deposit now
the Treasury can't do anything unless
Congress tells them it's okay so it's
you can't write the checks without the
Congress telling you so if you kind of
think about this relationship the head
of the Federal Reserve has some
functions as the head of the the bank
that that would naturally tend to
conflict with the Treasury Department
and like we've pointed out because these
institutions have been worked out at
different moments in American history
some of the relationships are not very
clear so we were saying a lot of it
comes down to politics and the politics
depends on the individuals who hold the
jobs that they have and one thing I find
fascinating is that it doesn't
necessarily reflect their political
parties so you've had incredibly
positive relationships between
Republican appointees and I think the
famous example is Alan Greenspan at the
Federal Reserve having a great
relationship with Robert Rubin at the
Treasury in the Democratic Clinton
administration and Alan Greenspan in his
own accounts would say that he didn't
have the same good working relationship
with some of the Republican appointees
that had preceded secretary Rubin so you
don't necessarily have you know you had
good relationships with Paul Volcker at
the Federal Reserve with some
Republicans and not so much with some
Democrats and vice versa because Volkers
policies really put the economy into a
recession which was damaging for some
Democrats so it isn't necessarily a
partisan relationship I think what
people have pointed to since Ben
Bernanke was at the head of the Fed is
that some Federal Reserve chairs are
very good at going up on the hill and
talking to people and making clear to
the American public I know that's Ben
Bernanke's aim to try to open up and be
mystify the Fed and let them understand
why it does what it does and
burn it up but they've all had their own
styles and their own ability some people
are better at working with others and
also it depends on whether or not they
think that monetary policy is the
appropriate way to handle whatever the
crisis is or the secretary of the
Treasury might think that fiscal policy
is or is not the the best way you had a
shift in in policy in American
government between the federal
government wanting to control the
economy through taxing and spending
policy shifting to having the federal
reserve play a larger and a larger role
in moderating the economy so if we go
back to previous recessions there had
been the sense that in the George W Bush
administration we had almost mastered
the the recession the business cycle
that we had gotten so good at it
that the Federal Reserve was so able to
handle things that that we really
weren't going to have a major collapse
again and interest rates were low some
people would argue that the Federal
Reserve kept interest rates too low for
too long but people went into housing
markets for a variety of reasons and
again here you're going to get a variety
of explanations from across the
political divide about what was going on
but there was an undue perhaps emphasis
on housing and people were looking for
higher rates of return on their on their
deposit accounts and on their
investments and housing provided higher
and higher rates of return as housing
markets moved to people who had worse
and worse credit histories so you tend
to pay a higher rate of interest when
you have a worse credit rating now the
financial services industry again
depending on on what your view of the
industry is whether responding to a
consumer need or acting responsibly
depending again on where you sit on a
political spectrum but the financial
services industry responded by providing
products that provided higher interest
rates and some of these were highly
risky and when they collapsed they were
so complicated
that it was unclear who actually even
was responsible for the mortgage that
was ultimately at the endpoint and when
you had a massive collapse in such an
important segment
the American financial services market
you had the threat that the whole system
will come down so you started to see
some hedge funds early on collapse the
Bear Stearns and and then you started
you had runs on the commercial paper
market leading up to 2010 / 2008 events
and then in September 2008 you started
to have massive collapses of major
institutions well in a major reform
legislation that came out of 2008 was
the dodd-frank reform act that tried to
change the worst practices of the system
so that we wouldn't have another
financial crisis so one of the more
obvious results was the creation of the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau so
we have a new agency that was created
and the idea here was that there would
be an emphasis on the consumer in the
financial services marketplace so when
people go out to make a home loan they
have a good understanding of what
they're actually borrowing and what
their obligations are so when they go
into the rest of the financial services
marketplace they understand when they're
taking on risk when they're engaging
volatility because sometimes we want
more risk and volatility but it's
important for the consumer to understand
when they're taking that risk on or
maybe if it's with retirement money and
they don't want it to understand when
they are not so that has been one new
area that's opened up and and even in
areas like home loan or excuse me
student loans and some other things
we've seen important initiatives that
have come out of that agencies the other
big area has to do with the Volcker Rule
so trying to rein in some of what people
perceive to be the most risky practices
of some of the major banks in terms of
trading securities on their own book or
are they providing services for
customers or they are you know trying to
bring back the spirit of the old
glass-steagall where banks do what banks
do and the investment banking industry
does what the investment banking
industry does the my goal in writing the
book was not to place emphasis on any
one policy prescription for the future
my goal was to give people an
understanding of the entirety of the
system so that they could understand the
components as they relate to each other
and they could make up their own mind
about whether or not they think the
emphasis should be put on stopping
campaign contributions from Wall Street
or should the emphasis be on the comment
period when the agencies are making
rules should that be the area that they
should wear they should make their mark
should they join an interest group
should political parties where do they
think in the system would be the most
effective place to press for real change
and not just express frustration with
the system but really be able to
understand who is it when we say the
government does something the government
doesn't do anything some agency or some
part or a presidential administration
there is a component of the government
that's actually acting but it's helping
or harming you where is it identify it
and come up with solutions because
that's the only way that that's that's
the way banks operate and that's the way
financial services industry operates so
the only way that you could you could
address those issues is by working
through the same channel and so I hope
to take away is for people to understand
themselves where the where they see the
problem and be able to go forward and
and work within those constraints